what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to talking Thrones now that season
seven is officially over I want to talk
about a character who still has some
unfinished business heading into the
last season Arya Stark is well known for
having a hit list of people she has
attended on killing but she has yet to
scratch all of those names off for her
list in this season 7 finale she was the
one who delivered the fatal blow to
Littlefinger although he wasn't on her
list but that did get me thinking who
could she kill next I want to go over
the current state of her list and talk
about which characters she is likely to
kill before this series ends
ever since Ahri has started to keep
track of people she wanted to kill it
has changed several times over the years
and because it has changed so many times
I want to go over every name that was on
our list at one time or another then I
will talk about who is currently left on
the list and whether or not I think she
will take them out before I go through
the names I want to show you a clip from
season six when Arya was training with
the wife this was the last time Arya
named off everyone she wanted to kill
who else was a nice dogs funny little
list Gregor Clegane
will defray
[Music]
that's a short list
[Music]
I can't be everyone want to kill
are you sure you're not forgetting
someone
which name would you like Agatha speak
for some reason there are a lot of names
missing from our list now and I'm not
exactly sure why because some of these
people are still alive but let's go
through the actual names that were on
her list then see who has left for her
to scratch off herself the first name on
her list was Joffrey and he was put on
our list in the very first season of the
show and for very good reasons
he bullied her friend the butcher's boy
who ended up being killed by the Hound
all because of this little fight that
they got into an aria took this very
personal not to mention Joffrey and
Cersei won at her dire wolf Nymeria
killed because she bit him but as we all
know lady was killed instead but to top
it all off Joffrey ended up ordering the
execution of arias father Ned Stark it's
pretty obvious why Aria has wanted him
dead all these years but as we all know
Joffrey was poisoned during his wedding
so Aria never got to scratch his name
off for herself when Arya and Sansa
reunited in season seven she expressed a
Songza how angry she was when she heard
someone else killed Joffrey because he
was always at the top of her list and
she wanted to do it herself the next
person that was on her list was the
Hound and he was put there because he
actually killed the butcher's boy but
after she spent quite some time with the
Hound she really got to know him and she
ended up taking him off of the list
which she had to admit to the wife
during one of their training exercises
she assumed the Hound was gonna die
after Brienne kicked his ass but in
season eight I think they will meet
again and this is one reunion I am
really looking forward to because I know
they're gonna get along great with each
other plus I really want to see them
fight together the Hound will be heading
north too so it's just a matter of time
before they reconnect ser Meryn Trant
was also on her list because he was the
one who killed her water dancing teacher
Syrio Forel and this was one named Oreo
was actually able to scratch off and she
didn't disappoint when she did sir Ellen
Payne was on her list for beheading her
father and Ned Stark in Sorrell and
Payne is actually still alive but he has
not been seen on the television show for
a very long time the actor ended up
getting cancer and the doctors told him
he was going to die but after he had an
operation they were able to save his
life and as far as I know he is
cancer-free but I do not think they're
gonna be bringing him back in
to the story while Aria was at the house
of black and white in season six she
named everyone that was on her list and
she no longer had Ilyn Payne on there so
that must be for a reason the show
writers must not intend on bringing this
character back but who really knows they
could always recast him but with only a
few episodes left it doesn't really seem
likely Tywin Lannister was also on her
list and he was the mastermind behind
the red wedding in REO was also his cup
bearer so she was well aware of him
plotting against her brother Robb Stark
considering they were at war with one
another but as we all know Tyrion
Lannister actually killed Tywin before
Arya could ever see him again
paula ver was on her list for killing
her friend Lonnie with her sword needle
and Paula ver was another name Arya was
able to scratch all for herself while
she was with the Hound they ran into him
Annan in and that's when Arya was able
to get needle back off of him and Pierce
it through his throat just like he did
to Lonnie and roared was another name
that was on her list he actually
threatened to rape Arya but she killed
him by piercing needle through his heart
beric Dondarrion and Thoris of Mir were
on her list for selling injury off the
Melisandre and Thoros of Mir ended up
dying beyond the wall when they went to
capture a wight and we really can't
confirm or deny whether or not barek is
still alive berrak was at
eastwatch-by-the-sea what torment when
the night king attacked the wall would
Vissarion and the wall came crumbling
down and we didn't see whether or not
they survived the wall collapsing it did
look like they were able to get to the
other side of the wall that didn't
actually fall so if Barrack did survive
I don't think Oreo will still kill him
anyway considering Gentry did end up
forgiving him and Thoros I think if Arya
would become aware of this she will
learn to live with it too plus the last
time Orion aimed off her list she was no
longer naming Barrack or Thoreau's on
there either
I'm not sure why they keep changing her
list but it has to be for a reason I can
really only assume it's because she will
no longer try to kill them the writers
probably knew she would never cross
paths with them again so they just had
her stop saying their names Walder Frey
was on her less due to the red wedding
but as we saw in the season 7 premiere
Arya basically wiped out his entire
house by using his face to poison
everyone this was another name Orio was
able to personally scratch off
Melisandre was another
person aurilla had listed to kill
because she was the one who actually
took Gendry away in orion knew she had
evil intentions this was actually one
person I thought Aria would kill simply
because Melisandre told her they would
meet again I thought they would cross
paths while they were travelling since
Aria was heading home to the north and
Melisandre was told to go south or she
would be executed I was really hoping
they would meet again but they never did
Melisandre made it the Dragonstone and
she was the main reason Daenerys and
John were able to meet and when Jon Snow
arrived on Dragonstone she told Varys
that her job was done she connected ice
with fire so now she was going to leave
Westeros and we have no idea if we're
ever gonna see her again or not
Melisandre was another name that was
taken off arias list for some reason in
season 4 when Aria was with the Hound
she listed off her names before she went
to sleep and she did say the red woman
but in season 6 during her training at
the house and black and white
her name was no longer being said this
makes me think they may never see each
other again unfortunately now I know the
actress was pregnant which did conflict
with her filming schedule so that could
be the reason why she left this show so
abruptly personally I was not a fan of
the way they just had Melisandre up and
leave the plot but I am really hoping we
see her again in season 8 but the way
things are being written that might be
the last time we ever see her I think if
the show writers planned on writing
Melisandre out of the show they should
have just had Aria kill her but I'm
gonna hold out hope that she does show
up again before Jon made her leave the
north she did remind him that he could
use her against the army of the Dead
she told Jon that she could help him win
this war which I always found very
interesting I would like to see her
again just to see what other kind of
tricks that she might have up her sleeve
but don't hold your breath there are two
names left on her list and both of these
people are alive and still working
together which are Cersei and the
mountain
aurilla has wanted to kill the mountain
since he was torturing people back at
Harrenhal back when she was Tywin's cup
bearer and she wanted Cersei dead since
season 1 I think there is a good chance
Arya could kill both of them in the
books Maggy the Frog said Cersei would
be killed by the valonqar which is the
little brother but in the television
show this was never stated which means
just about anyone with the right
opportunity could kill Cersei one of
arias goals this season was
kill Cersei but after she found out John
and sanso had retaken Winterfell she
went home instead but that doesn't mean
she will never leave again to finish off
her list someone seriously needs to kill
Cersei so who better to do it than Arya
who has wanted her dead since the
beginning of this series she could also
kill the mountain too but I still feel
like the Hound will be the one to take
him down the writers have been doing so
much fanservice lately I wouldn't be
surprised if they gave us cleganebowl to
the Hound confronted him at the dragon
pit and he told him you know who is
coming for you brother you've always
known and I think the Hound was actually
talking about himself and I'm even more
convinced the Hound will kill him one
day but I might be wrong about that I
know a few of you have been leaving
comments about Arya wearing someone
else's face to actually kill Cersei I
know some of you think she could wear
Littlefinger's face and some of you
believe she will wear Jaime's face and
that's how she will be able to get close
enough to kill her I'm not so sure
either one of these things are actually
gonna happen but Jaime is on his way
north most likely to Winterfell this
would give Aria the right opportunity to
kill Jaime if she wanted to but he was
actually never on her list he did push
brain out of the window and that's
certainly a good enough reason for Arya
don't want to kill him if she found this
out but I don't think Jamie's fate is in
the hands of Arya right now I still
believe Jaime will die saving one of the
Starks or maybe even die saving Brienne
Arya could always use his face
afterwards regardless of how he dies
then she could go south and greet with
Cersei as Jaime and kill her
Jaime is much bigger than Arya though
but we have seen Arya take the same
shape as the person whose face she is
actually wearing when she wore Walder
Frey's face she did appear to be much
taller so if she's got Jaime's face she
could pass herself off as him too no
matter what the height is since they
left the valonqar part of the prophecy
out of the show I think Arya has just a
good a chance of killing Cersei as
anyone else with her skill set I am very
confident she could get it done with
ease everyone that wants to kill Cersei
the most is going to be in the North
fighting against the army of the dead so
it's hard to say which person will
actually go back to King's Landing to
take her out
unless Cersei would come north of course
but I don't see her ever doing that what
do you all think about this though the
last time Arya named off her list she
only had Cersei Walder Frey in the
mountain on there and she already killed
Walder Frey
so out of Searcy in the mountain which
one do you think she is most likely to
kill leave it down in the comments and
let's see what's one gets the most votes
in my opinion I think it would have to
be Cersei especially since she wanted to
kill her this season but she changed her
mind for the time being let me know what
you think though and I have to thank you
all for watching today's video I really
do appreciate that and I also want to
thank all of you generous people on
patreon thank you for your support I
hope you all have a great day bye
[Music]
[Music]
you